a lot of cultures in
in the forest are eating chickpeas three
times a day just to get
good source of protein
and also
us israel is the and all our neighbors
in the middle east
eat hummus for generations so i think
in general it was highly valued as a
good source of protein very nutritious
and
there are even
articles that i read that
eating chickpea makes you happy
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
talking about
chickpeas yes chickpeas meet talina
chustan the ceo of vinovopro
tally is an experienced ceo and strategy
leader in global companies she brings
over 20 years of experience in mergers
and acquisitions and in expanding
product lines using innovative
strategies and brand management tally
holds a ba in economics and an mba both
from tel aviv university
welcome to 20 minute leaders the ceo of
innova pro welcome thank you very much
michael
happy to be here you know
thank you very very much for being here
and looking at the future of food and
food tech and you know the israel export
institute but but looking you know more
strategically about how we as humanity
are are you know taking in our protein
and taking in the the writing greetings
that we need and and breaking some of
the preconceived notions that we might
have and looking to the future of
sustainability and and where you know we
we ought to be is the civilization i'm
excited to have both a high level
conversation with you about where
humanity is going but also going deep
into innovapro and understanding you
know the chickpea revolution that you're
part of and what that means so
before we even get into all of that ali
you know how did you get your career to
be shaping into food tech how did that
happen
so i think all good things happen by
chance so i started my life at the cpg
business
and i was an accountant
and after i started my mba with two
majors finance and marketing i fell in
love with the marketing side
and then started started my career as a
as a marketing i was in marketing i was
a leading
i was i was part of teams that led
a beautiful launches of
food products to new markets like a tea
product and the in the natural health
product
and then move to totally different areas
the marketing passion took me
my journey was going through
a food companies communication companies
where i dealt a lot with innovation and
mergers and acquisition
and
reached also
a infrastructure companies who were
dealing a lot with sustainability
so then i got the sustainability
sustainability bug also implemented in
me so marketing and sustainability
are the core uh of of my passion and uh
i met the founder of innovo pro dr
shmulovic after 20 years
in big corporates with global activity
and then i met my third passion which is
chickpea and plant-based proteins and
here here we are
so to take me back to to when you met
the founder of innova pro and you know
well what did you discover what was this
aha moment for you
that made you want to join as a chief
executive officer of this company and
be at the forefront of of a shift in
consumer behavior
so i think everything joined into into
one
i i realized that
the future of food
is connected very strongly
to new technologies of plant-based
proteins
and also that
the well-being of humanity as you said
in the beginning
is very much connected to what we eat
how we behave
and
i think both things
um
joined together
and
i studied a lot
prior to me entering innovopro as the
first employee i studied the for six
months the
the ecosystem and the competition and
the consumer behavior
and i realized that this is
not just the future of food but also
something that is important to me
personally that will probably affect the
future of our children
and
i was the first employee of innova pro
beautiful okay tally tell me you know
before we dive into innova pro and some
of the strategy and milestones and
vision um what is it about chickpeas
that that makes sense why why is this a
viable solution and for what
i think chickpeas were always like the
the
royal
er legume
because it always had
a
was connected with a lot of cultures it
was connected with health
and also there are many studies that are
connecting
chickpeas to many health health
conditions
and i think
chickpea was always a
a legume that was considered very rich
in protein and better for human health a
lot of cultures in
in the forest are eating chickpeas three
times a day just to get
good source of protein
and also
us israel is the and all our neighbors
in the middle east eat hummus for
generations so i think
in general it was highly valued as a
good source of protein very nutritious
and
there are even a
articles that i read that
eating chickpea makes you happy
so it's not a surprise that
many
important magazines and the researchers
they are calling now the chickpea
phenomena the mighty chickpea it's one
of the leading
emerging pulses and the
interesting consume that are in the
interest of consumers
and people would like to see more and
more
chickpeas in general in their
diet
and of course since we are
very busy people we go to work even in
covid in innovopro we come to work every
day
so i think uh it's not possible for us
anymore to cook three times
a chickpea meal a day
and we rely
a lot
on food companies
and what we call processed food
and processed food doesn't have to be
bad right now it's not that good
consumers are really
concerned about what they see
on a lot of the packaging
uh in supermarkets and when they buy
online they read the list of ingredients
they see e numbers the same ingredients
that they cannot pronounce their names
and they are concerned
and i think this movement of consumers
that are
putting back in the shelf
products that they don't
find comfortable to eat anymore because
they are too processed
is the innova proper unity
what we offering is an ingredient
that can combine
in a
processed food however
it enables the creation of clean label
recipes
clean label product
with short list of
ingredients and of course recognizable
if you take for example i don't know
that you you are also from
this area so
probably for us imagining hummus as an
enabler for yogurt
might be surprising but
chickpea protein
is
a
a smart ingredient
it enables the creation
of clean label applications that are
very diversified
they can go from
a yogurt
with chickpea protein that you eat and
you really have a sense of creaminess
that you cannot suspect that it is
coming from
legume
it really tastes like dairy
or
ice creams or beverages all based on
chickpea protein
and with the nutritional value of their
similar dairy product
so this is what we're offering we're
offering an ingredient
that can
work
like a smart agent
in recipes
very easy to incorporate
very mild in taste
the biggest problem of consumers that
would like to do something good for the
environment
to reduce their
meat consumption to reduce their dairy
consumption what goes in the middle
between their wish and their acting is
the taste
not everyone can relate to the taste of
plant-based proteins
a lot of people report
that they cannot stand even the smell of
some
plant-based proteins like soy for
example
and
it's it's a challenge
to create plant-based protein products
that are also tasty
and i think this is another
a strong attribute or a
uniqueness of the chickpea protein of
inovopro because it has a neutral taste
so if you're combining this
uh
what we call the five pillars
it's like five important qualities that
this ingredient has in one
and it's hard to find them together
in other plants proteins
so it's about the clean label-ness
it's about of course the taste which is
the most important thing in food we
would like to enjoy when we eat not just
to
consume
and
the functionality which is important for
r d managers in those industrialized
food companies
and the sustainability
and
our process
is highly sustainable
meaning the chickpea itself
it's a rotational crop
it grows
uh
in the the farmers they use it as a
rotation rotational crop meaning it
brings back nitrogen to the soil
interesting
and we source it next to the factory
and then we apply our technology in the
end we get our cp pro 70.
and then
this smart agent is going to
many food companies and saving them a
lot of emissions
because instead of buying like five to
seven other
ingredients and sourcing them and
importing them and storing them and
logistically handling them they handle
one ingredient
that is doing basically a job of of many
more
so essentially what you're saying is
that you're both
sorry you're saying that there's both a
shift in consumer behavior that
consumers are looking for pro for
on-shelf products processed food that
have
ingredients obviously that they can they
can abbreviate and they can and they
know what they mean but then there's
also on the business side on the
logistics front on the emissions front
on the carbon footprint the ability for
companies to not just be more appealing
to consumers but to also create products
that taste better because of the
tasteless notion of of the
chickpeas but also in terms of the way
that it's being processed through the
smart agent that innova pro is creating
did i get that right absolutely yes i
think this is
the essence of of what we do
and so what what really was the catalyst
for all of this is this a new idea
that chickpeas can facilitate as a smart
agent for a lot of these processes is
this something new that we're just
discovering now another what's been the
blocker for us
to understand this in the last you know
50 years of of the industrialization of
processed food
it's a very good question and thank you
for that
we are eating plant-based proteins for
many years
the first era of plant-based protein was
soy protein
and
it's an industry of more than 60 years
that is extracting
a
the protein from a soy beans
in the way that is considered today by
consumers not sustainable because it's
using organic solvents in order to do
that
and and
more and more consumers not only
food companies also consumers are
concerned about the supply chain about
the processing way
so soy protein is a very good source of
protein very nutritious and it's the
first generation of plant-based proteins
however
its process is not necessarily a
sustainable one
and also the way it is
a normally produced it's about
the crop is growing in north america
then it's being shipped with a lot of
emissions in
ships into china's factory to be
processed and then coming back
all over to the west world to be
consumed so i think
this is another thing the supply chain
of soy protein is not locally it was
never created
about being local and about a cons and
about less emissions
and the second generation which is an
improvement of plant-based protein
was the p protein
which is a good source of protein
sometimes
the
the method is with solvent sometimes
without however
the challenge with p protein is the
taste
and
because it's a good source of protein a
lot of companies are using it and then
they need to mask the taste
with a lot of
helping agents and then
eventually we get those long list of
recipes
that
intimidate consumers again and also
the pea protein has its own challenges
in functionality solubility
and so on and the next generation always
we want something better the next
generation of protein
should compensate on on everything that
lacks in the in the first two
so we're offering the cp pro 70 as the
third generation
of proteins
that will be uh as you as we said
sustainable nutritious
tasty and functional all in one
way so where is the nova pro positioned
today in this market and and what is the
vision of when you're where you're
taking this company
so we started in
in israel with
today we're
a team of
more than 20
a multi-disciplinary
professionals coming from different
field
food technologies food engineer process
engineers biotechnologists
and
today we're looking
into being a platform
of chickpea based ingredients
we discovered that uh cp pro 70
can be the first
a pioneer in the
let's say list of products that are
available
from the chickpea
a we intend
to invest a lot in
research
and development in order
to utilize the side streams of our pro
of our process
because the chickpea has many more
inside not just the protein it has
fibers it has oil it has starch it has
sugars
and all of them are very interesting
ingredients that can contribute
to those food companies that are looking
for clean label ingredients
and on top of that
we
issued this year two new products that
are based on cp pro 70 but our blends
to offer
some kind of a short way to food
companies we issued the tvp which is a
texturized a plant-based protein that is
mainly used for the meat analog industry
it has a structure and it contributes to
the bite feeling when you eat a
impossible burger and you want to feel
the bite like like a meat so what you
really feel is those texturized proteins
the plant-based proteins inside so this
is one product that is a mixture
and our product was the first to be
launched based on chickpea protein
the second one was another interesting
solution for the bakery industry
it's a product that
mimics the egg white functionality
for a industrialized baking company
so they can create meringue for example
without the egg without the egg whites
oh very cool
very very cool and so tally i have to
ask is this trivial for the companies
that you're selling to
the food manufacturers do they
immediately understand what the cp 70
pro and what it means and what you know
what the solution is and how this can be
a solution that you know can be an
enabler for them for for many for many
things in their current supply chain of
products that they're building
is it trivial i think there is a lot of
curiosity about that
the r d teams in companies they
never mind if it's global companies like
nestle or the known where the r d teams
are huge
or
family owned companies in many countries
or even startups
everyone has curious people inside and
they want to discover
a new ingredients in order to become
more relevant to consumers so there is a
demand and there is a lot of
curiosity to find new ingredients to
find new solutions
the implementation part
is harder
and because
because
you know implementing is always the hard
part
it takes more than just
a trial in the lab so sometimes such
processes take some time
until those companies reach enough
a
a maturity enough understanding
enough
they're building their own machine lines
sometimes
uh for plant-based yogurt sometimes the
machine that used for
a regular yogurt are not the same so
they need
maybe to buy sometimes new equipment or
to get their hands on some knowledge
that they didn't have before so it takes
some time but we see that the
the need is out there the demand is very
big
and more and more companies are getting
confident from seeing new launches of
other companies in other regions so it's
about the more the merrier
tali thank you very very much for
introducing me to the chickpea
revolution for two nova pro and and uh
for giving me a little bit of insight
into you know what's happening in the
food market both both from a consumer
behavior standpoint but also from from
from a company perspective of the
logistics and what what is now being
possible
through a lot of these solutions and and
i really appreciate your time and the
impact that you're having on on
everything obviously so thank you very
much and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you thank you for having me thank
you very much bye-bye
[Music]
you